[Música]
bienvenidos a las postales de campaña de
france 24 una cobertura especial de las
elecciones presidenciales en eeuu nunca
antes esta nación había estado tan
dividida y por eso el mundo entero está
muy pendiente de lo que suceda aquí
recorreremos el país de costa a costa
para contarles los temas más cruciales
en estas elecciones un viaje de más de
10 mil kilómetros que nos llevará por
los estados más indecisos pero también
los más decisivos esos llamados estados
pendulares y la primera parada es
carolina del norte
esta es nuestra primera parada carolina
del norte aquí los candidatos se pelean
por 15 votos electorales las encuestas
están muy ajustadas y dan una ventaja a
los demócratas que confían en recuperar
esta zona del país pero antes de entrar
en detalles vamos a conocer un poco
mejor esta parte del sur de eeuu
aunque sabemos de carolina del norte con
el océano atlántico al este y la
cordillera de los apalaches al oeste
carolina del norte es un estado de
llanura
antiguo estado esclavista cuenta con un
poco más de 10 millones de habitantes
otra particularidad una fuerte comunidad
de cristianos evangélicos carolina del
norte es parte del cinturón bíblico el
punto fuerte del estado ha sido durante
mucho tiempo la agricultura en
particular el tabaco hoy en día carolina
del norte cuenta también con alta
tecnología alrededor del triángulo de
investigación de su capital real y a
nivel político el estado voto demócrata
hasta 1964 antes de la adopción de la
ley sobre los derechos civiles desde
entonces en su mayoría se vota
republicano es un compendio de américa
por un lado las ciudades donde viven los
estudiantes y los moderados y por otro
las campañas blancas y conservadoras
pero son sobre todo los votantes
afroamericanos los que podrían marcar la
diferencia pesan el 22% del electorado
fue su movilización lo que permitió a
barack obama ganar el estado y su
abstención lo que le dio el estado a
donald trump
[Música]
estamos pensando en la capital
financiera de carolina del norte en el
2016 esta ciudad se convirtió en el
escenario de varias protestas tras la
muerte de un hombre afroamericano a
manos de la policía cuatro años después
la historia se repite pero con otro
nombre el de george floyd el grito sigue
siendo el mismo
black life matter de la noche a la
mañana miles de estadounidenses salieron
a la calle para exigir el fin de la
violencia policial y aquí se lo hicieron
como en otras ciudades con murales como
este hemos querido hablar con sus
vecinos y esto es lo que nos han contado
políticos y trabajadores de campañas
todos ustedes tienen que saber que las
vidas de los negros importan en cada
elección y en la vida cotidiana
queremos asegurarnos de que nuestras
vidas sean valoradas que somos personas
y hemos ayudado a construir estas
grandes ciudades algunos de los tiroteos
han sucedido teniendo afroamericanos en
la fuerza policial para que todos se
sientan seguros e incluidos en este
movimiento es para asegurarnos de que
todas las minorías o todas las personas
que tengan problemas o que se hayan
sentido segregados en algún punto sepan
sepan que el estamos juntos que el
problema lo tenemos que cambiar cada uno
con ha sido el resultado de estas
movilizaciones históricas se ha
conseguido lo que se buscaba un equipo
de france 24 ha viajado hasta raleigh la
capital del estado para buscar
respuestas
los llamaremos michael y yes y tienen 23
años y qué hicieron juntos en rally la
capital del estado de carolina del norte
al igual que muchos miembros de la
comunidad afroamericana del estado
participaron en los últimos meses en
movimientos para combatir la desigualdad
racial y la violencia policial aceptaron
hablar con nosotros pero con la
condición de que se dejen las máscaras
puestas
y creo que hay una justicia de dos
niveles algo institucional saben los
afroamericanos son una especie de blanco
fácil en cierta percepción de la
pirámide social que para ellos tienen
que permanecer así
y ellos es el poder judicial del estado
y por supuesto la fuerza pública
creo que la policía puede cambiar con
mucho entrenamiento el entrenamiento que
les haga recordar las reglas y su nuevo
compromiso para servir al público
ahí es donde tienen que empezar
la reforma de la policía es precisamente
la intención de las autoridades
estatales pero la ejecución del proyecto
solo puede ser tarea de las propias
fuerzas de seguridad en la academia de
policía de rally
esta será la misión del sargento bill y
karim después de más de 20 años de
rastrear el crimen en las calles este
suboficial está ahora a cargo de
entrenar a la nueva generación de
oficiales de policía están bajo un poco
de presión no así cuando les hablo
tienen que moverse rápido y en su primer
día en la academia los aprendices son el
blanco directo de un nuevo discurso por
nadie
un compromiso comienza para ustedes y
este compromiso será para que triunfen
respetando los principios de esta
escuela una de las principales cosas que
tienen que entender para ser eficaz como
oficial de policía es la compasión la
compasión no es opcional es una
obligación todo ser humano merece
responder aprenderán a mostrar este
respeto a todos al que vive en la calle
y al propio presidente la compasión es
la clave ha sido claro clase de
esperanza
de lugar
hopper
en un país donde abundan los escándalos
de abusos policiales estos candidatos
simplemente no pueden permitirse cometer
errores
el sargento gary recibe sus órdenes
directamente de la oficina del
gobernador y tiene carta blanca para
despedir a cualquiera que no apoye la
idea de una fuerza policial más social
que nadie prefiere tratar con un mal
policía cuando puede tener uno bueno una
vez que decimos eso puedo ver que
estamos haciendo un buen trabajo
concretamente conocí muy pocos policías
malos porque no se quedan con nosotros
mucho tiempo y realmente no hay lugar
para ellos aquí
en rally como en el resto del país el
caso de workflow está ejerciendo una
presión política muy fuerte sobre las
fuerzas de seguridad una presión que al
menos obliga a la policía a cambiar su
comunicación
[Música]
y para conocer más detalles sobre cómo
usarlo está instigado a ese cambio desde
dentro
hemos querido conversar con la alcaldesa
de esta ciudad
la demócrata baila gels una mujer que
además ha hecho historia cuando en el
2017 se convirtió en la primera
alcaldesa afroamericana en esta ciudad
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
el día de hoy alcaldesa en el año 2016
tras un enfrentamiento tras un tiroteo
un joven afroamericano 15 le montó a
scott a resultó fallecido por este
tiroteo usted puso en marcha un amplio
plan de siete puntos para acabar con las
diferencias raciales y de clases
realmente ese plan ha funcionado
creo que logramos lo que nos propusimos
hacer asegurarnos que las personas se
entendieran que sabíamos que necesitaban
vivienda que sabíamos que necesitaban
trabajos pero también empezamos con la
reforma el presidente obama organizó un
grupo de trabajo para estudiar el
trabajo policial y empezamos con eso fue
de efectivo en su momento sí pero las
cosas cambian y tenemos que responder a
los problemas actuales
creo que ahora debemos hacer más como
alcaldesa de esta ciudad usted es
responsable de mantener el orden qué
cambios cree que serían necesarios
dentro de la policía para cumplir este
objetivo
en este momento necesitamos la confianza
de la comunidad que sepan que estamos
aquí en realidad para ayudar y resolver
crímenes reales y no para acusar o para
estar en una situación donde se
discrimine a ciertas personas no hay que
actuar de manera innecesaria necesitamos
recuperar esa confianza la brutalidad
policial contra la población
afroamericana es algo que
desgraciadamente se ha extendido a nivel
nacional y en algunas zonas incluso se
han denunciado atentados contra derechos
civiles en el sentido de que se está
poniendo dificultades para que la
población afroamericana vaya a votar es
algo que ocurre también aquí en carolina
del norte
no diría que haya denuncias creo que es
exactamente el caso cuando hablamos
sobre tener un gobierno federal o cuando
el presidente afirma que debería haber
policías en los puestos de votación y en
los lugares de votación
eso es supresión manipulación para que
los afro américa
no puedan tener un impacto en las
elecciones eso es realmente la supresión
de votantes está ocurriendo y es algo
que necesitamos solucionar
necesitamos solucionarlo muy pronto si
no estaremos tan divididos en este país
que no estoy segura de que podamos
garantizar que no volverá a ocurrir la
violencia que hemos visto periódicamente
puede ser mucho peor
works usted cree que la polarizada
situación que atraviesa ahora mismo el
país impulsará a los votantes
afroamericanos a ir más a las urnas este
próximo 3 de noviembre en el día sé que
lo están lo sé porque en el primer día
de votación tuvimos un 50% más que en
2016 o en 2012 estamos viendo a los
votantes salir creo que el presidente
realmente ha hecho que la gente se
pregunte puedo seguir con esto otros
cuatro años están saliendo a apoyar a
joe biden ya kamala harris creo que
tener a una mujer afroamericana como
vicepresidenta nominada en el partido
demócrata ha sido una gran ayuda para
que las personas salgan y voten
especialmente las mujeres afroamericanas
quien no quisiera que su hija
una mujer exitosa a una mujer
afroamericana triunfando con esta gran
oportunidad
creo que el voto afroamericano tiene el
poder de decidir quién va a ganar estas
próximas elecciones presidenciales
eboué absolutamente dependerá de los
votantes afroamericanos he estado
visitando a las personas para que salgan
a votar muy muy temprano sabemos que
somos un estado decisivo y sabemos que
habrá una diferencia en el colegio
electoral pero también sabemos que
tenemos una fuerte población
afroamericana en el estado y que cada
uno de nosotros debe votar
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
el día de hoy
gracias por invitarme
ah
[Música]
el demócrata joe biden apuesta por una
reforma policial pero el presidente
estadounidense donald trump solo confía
en la ley y el orden para enderezar el
país un país en el que hay otros grupos
de votantes que también serán muy
decisivos en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales como son los evangélicos
y para conocer los ponemos rumbo a
nuestro siguiente destino
georgia acompáñenos en este viaje a
través de nuestras redes sociales o en
la página web de france 24 punto com
[Música]
[Aplausos]